so today I want to take a different
approach with this subject because it's
a very sensitive subject to many
including myself for many years and I
want to talk to you about anxiety
attacks and panic attacks and what that
has to do with my life because you know
so many times as a CEO I run a business
where I have many many employees and
many agents and I have responsibilities
with different carriers and companies
such as AI G's and nationwide and big
insurance companies and you know
relationship with my family my kids my
friends my commitments to the community
different things that I have to do and
this is a very difficult subject to talk
about sometimes because you know as CEOs
you don't see a lot of times us talk
about this and entrepreneurs talk about
this because in private settings when
we're together five ten fifteen of us
and we're talking openly talking about
is very normal but sometimes other
people who see CEOs CEOs feel like they
have to live this perfect life and this
perfect thing that everybody you stay
positive and you go out there and do
this and you do that and all this stuff
that everybody knows how to do that we
don't talk about the real life and real
things that a CEO struggles with and
that doesn't inspire other people to do
it because I want to tell you about some
of the things I've struggled with with
anxiety attacks and panic attacks so uh
you'll see how that's affected me and
what I did about it so I remember when I
lived in Iran I grew up in an
environment where there's a lot of
uncertainty my father never let me go
play outside because you didn't trust
your kids to be on seconds it was a lot
of kidnapping and different things that
was happening so you know that had me
grown up in an environment with a
certain level of confinement from
parents to protect you because you
didn't want to see anything bad
happening and from there how many days
we go to Germany we're living in a
refugee camp and I remember when I was
11 years old in Germany and I didn't
speak German and I got into a fight with
with a group of kids at this refugee
camp
and I had a hard time making friends in
Germany and so I am from Iran in Germany
I experienced a little bit of
discrimination because I'm from Iran and
what are you doing coming to Germany and
why are you here go back to your own
country and I had an anxiety attack and
had all this anxiety because I didn't
know how to make friends with the people
that I'm not accepted at and my father's
not there
my father's in Iran and and he's trying
to come to us so we can all meet in u.s.
and my family goes through a divorce
these are many things that people go
through that was my life and eventually
in November 28 we come to the States and
then I'm over here and I go to school
after school I joined the army and then
the first week of joining army you know
you have a lot of different pressures
and I remember one time I was you know
had this pressure of not wanting to come
back to where I'm from and I had to
graduate from the Army and one day we
had to dig foxholes and I dug two
foxholes you're only supposed to do one
and the foxhole is six feet by six feet
by three feet wide and you know we were
trying to meet a commitment and a
deadline that we had to get this thing
going because if you don't do it on time
if you're on war and you're going to
have this and all this stuff in and then
and I had an anxiety attack and I went
to the hospital and in the hospital my
temperature was one of four and a half
and has lost 20 pounds in a span of a
week and they put two IVs in me and the
doctor said it's not a big deal it's
just you pushed a little harder and this
is very where this is your body's way of
saying you push the limits so great so
came back and went into the army and the
later on it happened again at 24 years
old with my father and I didn't really
know what was going on with my body
because I couldn't breathe and at that
time I was in a lot of death and
financial turmoil and my dad's at the
hospital and my mother's back in Iran
and my sister's trying to get married
and my family's going through struggles
financially and I'm going through so all
of this adds up and then as a CEO I
become a CEO and I'm running a company
and I'm when I'm running a company
competitors everyday are telling me
and they're calling my staff and my
agents and telling them your CEO is not
capable of doing this and and calling
carriers and trying to bad-mouth us and
all the stuff that's going on it's a
typical part of a competitive
environment and you know one day I'm on
a three-week tour and I come back from
the three-week tour and when I come back
from the tour that night I go to meeting
and I stayed at the meeting till
midnight and then I come back home and I
had so many things on my mind my wife is
pregnant and I have some issues going on
with a in our company and then had some
issues going on with some relationships
with business people and then I'm trying
to you know get this other project going
I'm writing a book that's got me to do
some research late at night and I'm
going on four hours of sleep and I'm
really pushing it and I'm you know going
both ends you know and and one night
that night I came home it was 12 o'clock
at night 1 o'clock at night I couldn't
stop reading and next thing you know I
have a panic attack and Hoss you know
ambulance comes my father comes 2
o'clock in the morning ambulance comes
checks me out I get in the ambulance in
our community I go to the hospital and
when I go to the hospital the doctor
says you had a panic attack it's very
normal and why is it very normal well
what did you do you know you're when
you're pushing everything you got
sometimes this is your body of saying
slow down a little bit right okay great
so I was 33 34 at the time I said I am
going to study the subject of anxiety
attacks and panic attacks to understand
why this happens because it happened to
so many of my family members and friends
and many times were embarrassed to talk
about it so listen if today's message
helps you on on how you deal in if even
if one person gets something out of this
message here it did its purpose right
and I think more entrepreneurs need to
talk about this I think more
entrepreneur magazines and blogs need to
talk about this because there are a lot
of people that deal with this in their
everyday business and the more we know
how to cope with it and even today
nowadays not just entrepreneurs I had a
call I got from a friend of mine his 15
year old daughter was going through
issues and she wanted to take our life
away why well because today's pressures
of kids living with social media
Instagram sexting texting Facebook all
of these things that they're dealing
with it's a lot more than it's ever won
before and if we don't openly talk about
it I think that's worse than you know
trying to hold it together because I
believe there's one thing worse than
exploding and that's imploding imploding
is you're holding it holding it holding
it holding it hold it and then BOOM you
have no idea what happens with your body
exploding time to time it here's how I
feel here's how I feel here's how I feel
here's how I feel then you're releasing
it and feeling good about it and you
move on so you know anxiety is not
something that's a new thing you know
there's a lot of books here with a lot
of people who have been struggling with
anxiety Kennedy's Lincoln's a Jackson's
the list is long on high-profile people
jobs David Beckham athletes this is what
Lincoln said many many years ago Lincoln
was known for having anxiety attacks
Lincoln once said about what happened
with him an anxiety attacks he said we
live in the midst of alarms anxiety be
clouds the future we expect some new
disaster with each newspaper we read
newspaper when's the last time you and I
even paid attention to the newspaper
everything we get with news nowadays
it's within the second everything we
look at everything through Facebook
Twitter when somebody passes away we
hear about it through Twitter when
something something crisis happens an
earthquake a fraud something major it's
instant instant or phone notification
boom this is what happened notification
boom this is what happened and we're
doing our work we're doing what we're
doing and then boom that adds anxiety
that adds anxiety that that's anxiety
that that's exciting and we're trying to
get everything done so how do you live
and lead and build in a world where so
many things are going on simultaneously
that's what we're going to talk about
today and the good news is this there is
a formula to all of this there is a
formula to are all of this as long as
you become aware of it okay so let me
start off with the first thing let me
start off with the first thing I want to
talk to you about the difference between
being depressed and being bitter versus
being anxious and having panic attacks
panic attack is a byproduct of anxiety
attacks and so on one side the a panic
attacks and anxiety attacks on the other
side you have constant state of
depression and constant state of
bitterness very simple formula when
you're bitter and you're depressed your
mind is thinking about the past when
you're anxious and you have an anxiety
your mind is thinking about the future
so anytime you're going through these
two states it's important for you to
remind yourself to say okay I can't do
nothing about the past I cannot do
nothing but that person said they were
right and I told you so and they're
right maybe you were wrong and you can't
see thinking about replaying that in
your mind and that's creating to be to
be depressed so your challenge is not
anxiety or challenges depression we need
to get out of that stick as you can do
nothing about it or you're spending too
much time in the future anxiety so when
you identify this it's trying to bring
yourself back in the middle say the only
thing control right now is this and this
is what I'm going to try to control so
and in understanding that part and
balancing it is one thing but the other
side is also known the difference
between fear and anxiety because fear
and anxiety the only difference between
fear and anxiety is the timeline and the
lifespan because fear is sudden it comes
it goes anxiety has a longer lifespan
I'll explain I'm afraid I heard
something downstairs
what is it let me go downstairs to see
what it is maybe someones trying to open
a door and you're tense you go
downstairs it's your dog okay boom 22
second fear is gone
anxiety oh my god my baby is doing six
months how am I going to handle this
baby I've never been a father before
somebody told me I'm gonna be a good
father I don't know what a kid it how oh
my god there was no bought book do I
read one what if I can't afford it's
going to be expensive now I'm not going
to solve my can okay that's future
future future anxiety fear anxiety
there's a big difference between both
and it's simply a life span now anxiety
is actually part of our body so anytime
we are anxious
or we're afraid our body produces
adrenaline as a way to solve that issue
so adrenaline you're in a situation
where you get into a fight with somebody
all of us in your energies look boom
adrenaline you ready to fight because
there's danger
somebody's finding your body produces
adrenaline to be ready for that you're
there's war there's attack boom your
body produces adrenaline how to solve
that situation right but anxiety attacks
is like an alarm clock it's like an
alarm fire alarm some fire alarms are
more sensitive than others some people
the slightest little thing gets them to
go into the state and you got to control
the knob of how sensitive your fire
alarm is when you thinking you're afraid
when you're thinking you're having an
anxiety attack it's really not that big
of a deal lower the you know intensity
about sensitive your fire alarm is so
now all that stuff being said and done I
want to talk to you about what are some
of the symptoms of actual anxiety
attacks and anxiety disorders so let's
talk about the general symptoms of
anxiety okay number one is a challenge
with sleeping okay when you're anxious
you can't go to sleep because your brain
has gone all over the place and if you
don't let your imagination because
typically people who have more anxiety
attacks and more anxiety they have a
imagination bigger than the average mind
because it just goes places right so
challenge sleeping because your brain is
going all over the place you're thinking
about so many different things two
irrational fears
everybody's got fears you know spiders
snake dark height but irrational fears
that are non-existent that is the guy
that's going to give you anxiety three
muscle tension is a symptom of anxiety
for is chronic indigestion
IBS you've heard of it irritable bowel
syndrome that's part of a symptoms five
stage fright if you have to speak on
stage and all of a sudden you haven't
too much anxiety because you're afraid
of speaking it from everybody again
because of what other people think it's
part of it six panic attacks panic
attacks feel like a heart attack but
it's not a heart attack shortness of
breath sweating your hands are going to
sweat shaking a possible shakiness you
may feel like you're having a seizure
chest pain stomach pain faint
all a part of it and a lot of anxiety
could lead to panic if you don't control
your imagination flashbacks if you're
constantly reliving embarrassing moment
of your life or things that you did that
mess with your mind I was watching a
video the other day that dunk that Vince
Carter dumped on a seven-foot two-inch
guy and this 7-foot two-inch guy had the
opportunity to come and play in the NBA
and the Olympics
Vince Carter six six jumps over a seven
foot two guy well he got the offer to
come to the NBA the only reason he
didn't accept that is because he was so
embarrassed that it was the most viewed
dunk of all time that he didn't want to
complain the NBA tilted he struggles
with it this guy because it was an
embarrassing moment he kept playing
replaying reliving in his mind that's
going to create anxiety number eight
compulsive behavior feeling like you
have to be perfect that's going to
create anxiety your family made you know
maybe you had a military father that was
you have to be perfect everything's got
to be perfect that's going to create
anxiety compulsive disorders thinking
they have to do everything right that'll
create anxiety self-doubt a little bit
of doubt is healthy because you want to
prove to yourself they can overcome it
but a constant self-doubt it's going to
create a lot of anxiety for you as well
so how to fight off anxiety okay very
simple always if if you're having
anxiety and it's a real symptom of
anxiety you always do breathing go back
to trying to breed the way you sleep
because the best state of breathing we
do is when we're sleeping
and we're the Comus will breathe right
that's the way you breathe when you
sleep try to breathe like that and it
generally works - except that you're
having a little bit of anxiety it's okay
you're having anxiety process it am i
thinking about the past no that's
depression I'm not being depressed right
now I'm not bitter right now I'm anxious
right now because I'm thinking about the
future can I do anything about it right
now
no come present good accept it three
your brain if you allow your brain your
brain will will will play tricks on you
regularly okay but remember you're in
charge your brain so let me give you an
analogy let's just say dog I have two
dogs so you walk your dogs on a leash
and generally where you don't want your
dogs to pee you can pull
the leash and they won't either when
they raise their leg take them to the
next place next place next line you pick
and choose here's okay and they go pee
in your own brain you can pull that
places your brain goes because there's
one person that's the captain under your
brain and that's you you dictate where
your brain is so change it up very
quickly change your state you leave that
place and you forget about it and
literally within 30 seconds you forgot
what you were worried about and being
anxious about and our last one is self
questioning actually when it's happening
and asking why am I having an anxiety
why am i have why is this anxiety being
created right now why am i thinking like
this wise has taken place and as you go
through you say oh okay this is not a
big deal it's fine I'm gonna be okay and
you move on and you when you do do that
it's almost like graduating that state
of anxiety and you feel incredible about
it because you can do that same exercise
again so a few basic things to help with
anxiety as well as this one I said
already focus on the present to do
something that's a routine go cook
something you know go make a puzzle go
something that's a routine way of doing
something laundry if you have a routine
on how you do laundry it gets your brain
to do routine so you don't think about
it next one is exercise there's nothing
better to release anxiety than to
exercise and a constant those who are
continuously exercising that fear that
anxiousness all leaves you when you
exercise because your body's moving if
you're in a place that you can't go
straight to the gym go walk the stairs
go a speed walk go do something where
your body is moving and that anxiety
will typically go away and communicate
your feelings sometimes
not talking about it with somebody else
is one of the biggest ways to continue
that state is you hold it that's the
imploding part talk about it with
somebody talk about it would appear if
you're an entrepreneur maybe you're not
comfortable sharing it with somebody
else find a peer that's also an
entrepreneur that it has been through as
well talking until generally tell my god
can't believe you telling me this that's
happened to me as well you're kidding me
no how do you overcome this oh you're an
athlete oh yeah this is normal it
happens how do you deal with this oh my
god this is okay so these are some of
the things you communicate with the
spouse communicate with a friend and if
your kids or family or somebody else
that's going through it is
and you don't communicate that with them
they're in that state you'll ask
yourself why is that person so anxious
depressed it's probably because they're
going through a certain process that
causes them to have anxiety you can
actually help them process that with
them okay so what intensifies anxiety
attacks your anger your anger will
intensify your anxiety so anger is fuel
to anxiety if you control if you allow
your anger to get out of control your
anxiety goes even higher level so anger
is generally stemmed from us telling the
world that I have a problem that I don't
think I can solve that's what a the
feeling and emotion of anger really is
I'm having a problem I don't know how to
solve it I'm so ticked off right now
Papa Papa Papa okay it's learning how to
take that same passion that anger that
you have instead up into feeling like
you can't solve it try to come up with a
solution and it goes away short life is
a short sentence short lifespan it has
if you can find and use that same energy
of anger to solve it instead of staying
into it as if you cannot solve it that's
all it means next time you're angry why
am i angry it's because I'm trying to
tell the world that I have a problem I
can solve yes I can stay present can I
solve it great it moves on so sync them
with anger some basic things of
breathing taking the time out do not
bottle up your feelings accept the
responsibility do not blame a lot of
time when a bad relationship or bad
business relationship or bad breakup or
something happens that you're upset at
the other person on what they did you
can't really control anything on that I
can take responsibility and what I can
do better and that's all I can control I
can get angry over them because they
don't want to change maybe and that's
okay it's not only maybe I didn't do
something that was right and I can work
on it take responsibility grudges
probably one of the worst things we can
do what happens in family friendships
business relationships cold shoulder I'm
just not going to talk to him I'm not
going to call them back I'm not going to
do this we hold this grudge grudges hurt
you more than anything else you've heard
the the thing before you know holding a
grudge is kind of like your whole
to coal it's on fire and you don't throw
it away you hold on to it and you're
really doing burning you know it's
letting go grudges is a big part of
anxiety laughing it off and accepting it
and trying to laugh off at your own a
craziness and your own madness it's
actually so effective when you do that
obviously exercising again metadata
meditating and prank it's very very
effective quiet moment pray meditate
it's incredibly effective when you do
that so now the next thing on how to
stop anxieties from leading into a panic
attack very basic stop believing your
brain all the time okay
your brain is not right all the time
they say listen to your heart not your
brain your brain can really mess with
you if you listen to your brain all the
time okay so a few things with panic
attack has to do with your diet and your
diet is avoiding the following alcohol
nicotine and coffee can create anxiety
because you're just so bottled up and
you're so wired up and if you do too
much of that you generally ever seen
somebody that drinks a lot of coffee
they're just so wired well that's that's
anxiety right there and anything is just
going to make it a bigger deal and it
really is if you can avoid it you can
avoid it I'm not a big fan of coffee my
staff and my teammates will tell you I'm
insane I'm crazy but I'm not a big fan
of coffee my wife thinks I'm nuts but I
don't drink coffee because it amps me up
even to hold the front level so if you
can avoid those things that can that can
also be a part to minimize situations
for anger exercise again as a part of it
how you recommend meeting with a
dietician or nutritionist someone that
knows what they're doing to find out
with your blood type to recommend things
that you are eating you shouldn't eat
that's very easy to do that you pay
somebody $100 $200 and they'll put that
together for you take your blood type
it's a very good thing to do if you meet
with a dieticians you can always find a
good one around next one that has to do
with anxiety and anger is overcoming
guilt so let's talk about overcoming
guilt I can't tell you how many friends
and family members I know that had to
overcome this and some that took 10 20
30 40 years
and guilt doesn't allow to live a happy
life the sooner you can identify and
overcome you'll the sooner you can live
a happy life okay
all of these are part of life but
entrepreneurs experience this more
because anxiety typically happens to
people that are more pressure type
situations military athletes TV media
politics and a debate entrepreneur
business owner and let me explain
something to you the more you want to
experience the higher level of
competition the more of a likelihood
there is that there's a possibility of
em and anxiety so some people tell you I
that's exactly why I don't want to be an
entrepreneur an athlete and military and
Papa Papa that's fine I want to get the
juice of life and sometimes the juice of
life means putting yourself in
situations that you need to learn how to
cope with yourself and if you do that
that's what leads to become a no leader
remember at the beginning of the video I
have not yet met a strong man or a woman
without an easy past with an easy pass
because they don't go together your body
needs to be torn to become a stronger
muscle that's the same thing with a
leader and an entrepreneur the bigger
the Empire you want to build sometimes
you need to go through that the ripping
of the muscle the ripping of the mind
the ripping of a new mindset that you
got to go through to reach those new
heights overcoming guilt guilt is a
crippling and it is important emotion of
human body to one understand why you're
guilty to acknowledge your guilt 3
empathize because empathy is the
greatest human nature and human emotion
and a you know when you understand
someone else's pain you are truly on the
path to forgiveness
so you got to empathize and why is that
person feeling that way why did that
person do this why is that person if I
was in that situation how would I act
and why is that person thinking why did
that person do this so empathize then
its circumstances matter no one this is
the one part you know how we we all do
it you know we watch a sport game and so
if I was LeBron James I would have done
this if I was Kobe Bryant if I was you
know if I was the president if I was
this if I was that and if I was this
actor I would never we like to do this
if I was I would do this listen no one
and I
I mean no one knows every single detail
to any decision any human being ever
makes no one ever does we all want to
say that we would do something different
we're all guilty of it but to overcome
guilt you kind of need to you know see
what you can do and maybe try to have as
much information about why the decision
that was made by that person but
circumstances matter so you can't sit
there and say here's what that person
should have done right next learn from
your mistakes
easy everybody is going to make them
learn from them six change human beings
are capable of change but it comes only
with extreme dedication be nicer be
transparent next acknowledge toxic
relationships it's it's tough to let go
of toxic relationship because sometimes
those people are your cousins and
they're your friends of 10 15 20 years
and we feel guilty if we have to let go
a toxic relationship where a person
that's always negative around us and
doesn't believe in you and constantly
bashes you and constantly reminds you of
things that you did in the past that
were bad and you can't be an
entrepreneur you can't run a business
you can't go out there and look for me
like you don't have a degree Patrick you
can't go work for Morgan Stanley you
don't know what it is take your license
you went to the military because you
weren't that smart you're not the
brightest that whole thing that's toxic
those relationships need to be set aside
and you can revisit it five ten years
later and if they work on it great if
they don't maybe there's time for a new
relationship that is going to appear in
your life but you got to be strong
enough to let go those relationships to
move on eight forgive yourself first and
you'll forgive other people the hardest
person to ever forgive is yourself you
know there's there's a lot of people I
meet and they don't want to give it
everything they got I said what is it
there's something you're dealing with
inside you're bottling up you've got to
forgive yourself and the last one is
obviously let it go the famous song from
is it frozen as a frozen that says let
it go I'd listened to that song so many
I can't even tell you when two kids
birthday idea that a kid is a year old
and my son was a year and a half at that
time he thinks what's the four
characters names
what's the characters in from all off
all off and a girl's name is what was
I am sister Elsa he thought Elsa was
there to visit him you know we had to
listen to let it go a million times that
night and I walked away that night
saying Patrick you just got to let it go
you know from watching frozen anyways
you got to let it go okay so last one
power power to change I did a video on
how to create a habit and there's a
formula on how to create new habits and
how to get rid of bad habits link is on
the bottom if you haven't seen it go
watch that episode as well because it
has a lot to do with this on learning
how to create new habits but the power
to change our brain hates change
remember the brain doesn't like change
they make sure it remains the same and
stays comfortable it's on you the
programmer of the brain to make that
change if you the programmer doesn't do
it it won't change but you're in charge
of the programming so the power of
change 1 understand the need to change
to condition your brain on how to change
3 expect friction your brain is gonna
fight you on the new change that you're
trying to make 4 do not expect results
overnight it will not happen overnight 5
be realistic 6 have a certain time limit
7 get comfortable
meaning stayin in your comfort zone will
never allow you to realize you change so
get uncomfortable it is the word get
uncomfortable it's gonna be difficult at
times when you're going through it 8
keep yourself motivated and 9 adapt your
goals
so to recap today's message on what I
eventually had to do to that help me out
was I was trying to do 20 different
projects at the same time and one of the
things that's helped me out tremendously
is minimizing all of these multiple
activities or projects that I'm working
on to lesser things to put my focus on
the fewer things you can put your focus
on the better you do meaning I have to
worry about my family okay my faith my
family my health my business and the
friends that I have that matter to
the most and that's five things and
stuff that I got to do with hobbies
whatever else it may be the more I can
minimize those things the better it is
and the more efficient I can be in all
areas of my life if I can minimize the
projects I'm working on you will become
more effective the minute more you can
minimize the project you're trying to do
so few books to recommend to you age of
anxiety great book Zen golf a very very
good book this did a very very good book
because golf golfers struggle with
anxiety all the time especially you see
what happens to a lot of these golfers
when they're in the last they're about
to win the Masters how many golfers have
choked symptom anxiety normal this
happens to professional athletes last
second they need to shoot the ball they
don't Jordan comes back from retirement
he's facing the Orlando Magic Scottie
Pippen says I cannot believe Jordan gave
up the ball he typically wants to shoot
the ball Michael Jordan the greatest
basketball player of all time struggle
with anxiety this is a very normal thing
that people experience and the other
book I would tell you is it's called
it's called a Marty what's the name of
the other book it's called the panic and
anxiety relief by Jaden Taylor
Jaden J a why do n Taylor great book
Jaden I wish you would have written in a
print because we would have ordered a
thousand of your books but it's only on
eBook on Amazon they can order it I
highly recommend you order it I'm going
to put the link on the bottom for all
these books if you want to find and so
hopefully this message today helps you
realize that even as a CEO with all
these other responsibilities I have a
good marriage my wife and I have a very
good relationship we're working on
bettering our relationship all the time
I work on becoming a better father all
the time and spend time with my boys and
my family becoming a better brother a
better son a better friend a better
leader a better CEO and also at the same
time knowing that you can give
everything you got to max out the life
that you have but also at the same time
nobody's perfect
and when life happens all over the place
especially today's world with social
media and technology you need more tools
to be able to cope with anxiety with
depression with bitterness would panic
with your imagination with fears and the
moment you have tools you can be in
pressure type situations and knowing
here's how I process it it becomes
automatic and you'll lead better you'll
live better and you'll be happier that's
my message if you got any questions
about the content I share today feel
free to post your questions on the
bottom if you have any thoughts you want
to share with us maybe you use some of
these exercises I would love to hear
your story I suggest you watch it again
and take some more notes if you didn't
the first time and at last but not least
be sure to subscribe to this channel if
you have other people friends family
loved ones that maybe may be struggling
with the subject be sure to share this
video with them and have them learn from
it as well this is a subject that we
don't talk about many many time remember
18 percent of adults are experiencing
this odds are 1 out of 5 percent you
know would probably get a lot of value
from some of the content that was
hopefully shared in this video thanks
for watching
take care